operation compliance has to be one of
the most troubling things that I've ever
heard of in the city police officers
they got a ride with this compliance
they need to be on stopping on people
just knocking people in the head you
know I'm running a little chit business
entrepreneurs have said well look let
them catch me if they can right now the
city has decided we're gonna try to
catch you and we're gonna put together a
special unit to do so we all know
Detroit's in trouble
a bankrupt city full of crumbling houses
abandoned factory buildings and a fast
dwindling population yet in the midst of
all this collapse and decay former
Detroit Mayor David Bing announced a new
regulatory crackdown on code violating
businesses a crackdown he expected to
shut down 20 new small businesses a week
its operation compliance what I think
about operation compliance is I think
that they could be doing something
better if you clean up some of these
vacant lives I think cutting some of the
grants throughout the city and boarding
up somebody's house I'll clean up the
streets you're taking our tax dollars
clean it up these two business owners
have managed to keep their businesses
open on Livernois Avenue though many
other businesses along the road have
been targeted and shut down by operation
compliance in the preceding months you
know we call for these services as far
as someone breaks in and never show up
but yet still they want to come in you
know blackball you and close your
business because you might be a little
late paying fees or something like that
unnecessary restaurants in the you know
the city complaining about our signs out
in front of the buildings and all this
and then it ain't bother the people
downtown with their money but they match
them with the black communities in the
poor people it is hard to run a business
in Detroit it's taken me three years to
get approval for outside patio
Larry [ __ ] runs Cafe de [ __ ] a
remarkably successful restaurant and bar
in downtown Detroit you truly trying to
serve the public interest you would
simplify things but simplifying things
in Detroit means lost the jobs so
politicians rather try to tax me to
delve charged me to Dell
to keep their votes and keep their
relatives and I must say it like it is
keep certain friends all on a payroll
accidentally the city has created sort
of an anarchistic culture in the city
where many entrepreneurs especially the
smaller retailers and restaurant tours
simply forego getting the required
permits that the city is demanding of
them because it's too expensive and
because it often takes too long and
sometimes the inspections that are done
are of low quality so entrepreneurs have
said well look let them catch me if they
can right now the city has decided we're
going to try to catch you and we're
going to put together a special unit to
do so for people who would want to start
a business today in the city of Detroit
I really don't know how they would go
about even starting because the amount
of hurdles that the city has set up to
prevent them from going into business is
just overwhelming Steve Thomas owns
Detroit athletic company and has been
doing business in the city since age 11
when he started selling peanuts and hats
outside of Tiger Stadium even then
dealing with the city government was not
easy they would look for violations so
it might be the fire department and they
would come and they would say hey you're
set up too close to the fire hydrant
they would claim that there was some
rule we were in violation of they would
suggest to us that maybe we should give
him a hat or give him something in
return and then that was kind of how it
would get glossed over so he just
learned to comply I think it's really a
shameful thing that that people who were
entrusted with power would would become
that corrupt where they you know would
even shake down a little kid
representatives from the city of Detroit
declined multiple requests to be
interviewed for this video but the
government website says that we are
sending a message that if you are doing
business in the city you need to follow
the law imagine that in light of a
bankruptcy where businesses and people
have fled the city and droves they're
shutting down businesses that have
succeeded they may not have the
requisite permits the city wants but
that hasn't stopped patrons from
patronizing them and sharing their
resources in exchange for whatever
service the business is providing that
cries out for a different model
what's our paying for the compliance
certificate then I have to go
to all these different electrical that's
that set up appointments this person
might say I'm okay the next one said
well he shouldn't okayed you I look at
the bill I have to pay it sometime I
just really and I have said it to him
why don't I just come to you because it
seemed like what you want is money and
just give you one check luckily I could
afford it
but what about the person who just
starting out and the reputation that
they give their cousins or relatives or
friends who might think about doing it
and they said hey don't they rob you
[Music]
you